[Music]
this morning we are talking about how to
do a digital spring cleaning everything
from pictures on your phone or files on
your computer to that drawer filled with
old electronics a recent study from CNET
found that 74 of Americans have an
electronic device they no longer use
stored in their home and more than half
said that they don't have any plans of
getting rid of those devices CNS Dan
Ackerman is here to give us some tips
for tidying up your technology Dan good
morning how you doing hey good to see
you guys all right so what do we do with
those old phones the laptops devices the
Apple watches whatever it is that we're
not using what do we do with that stuff
everybody's got old stuff lying around a
good spring cleaning ideas to get rid of
it I wouldn't just throw it away the
first thing I would think of is
Recycling and almost anywhere you live
you're going to find electronics
recycling events I'm waiting for one
that's coming up in Prospect Park in
Brooklyn later in April and I'll bring
some stuff over there and a lot of
stores like Amazon or Best Buy will take
back Electronics even if you didn't buy
them there so it's very easy to recycle
stuff I forgot to do that I would then
resell or give it away just find a
second home for it so what services do
you recommend for those I know you
mentioned a couple but what services do
you recommend for that for reselling you
really have to do a lot of comparison
shopping there's places like back Market
you see them advertised all the time and
declutter and apple and Amazon and Best
Buy will take things in and give you
store credit or cash and what I find is
depending on the supply and demand for a
particular product maybe there's
something new coming out so everyone's
trying to get rid of the old ones the
prices are going to change a lot so
check you know daily and also you'll
probably get more in trading credit than
you will in cash and if you're going to
buy something new I guess that's okay
yeah so one of the things I think is
kind of cool is I've I've got every
single iPod from the first one to the
very last one really really yeah because
they still work they still work
um and but I find that it's sort of like
some of that stuff is highly sought
after well I was going to say it's going
to be like when our grandparents had
that old phonograph or a little
television and you're like wow that's
pretty cool but for the majority of
people who've got a lot of Just Junk in
their drawers the thing that's the
hardest to get rid of cables yes those
iPhone cables the iPod cables like
nobody uses those anymore so what do you
do with those but you don't want to get
rid of them because you feel like
Someday I'm gonna yeah I've got the
every year I opened up this big draw and
it's a mess it's a rats ready for the
apocalypse so what I do is I found these
cable ties that I love they're little
rubber ones with a wire inside they're a
little bit more expensive a bunch of
companies make them but man I just buy
these By The Crate load and I and I tie
everything up it's super neat and I make
sure I keep two of everything
a to c yeah one or two HDMI cable you
don't need every single one you ever
made but it's hard to convince yourself
to get rid of them keep two of
everything and just get rid of
everything else I just want to know
what's on the old iPod playlist the
first version
um but Dan I think a lot of us
I know I am overwhelmed by all the
photos on my cell phone and I I try to
organize them into albums recently but
it's hard to do that going back like to
000 photos so how do we do that where do
we start it's almost like your phone is
like that big shoe box and all the
pictures in it all stacked up and you
want to organize them the good thing is
one of the things AI is actually really
good at is helping you organize your
pictures and Google photos if you have a
Google device or you know Windows laptop
or the Apple photos app on your MacBook
or on your phone it's really good at
recognizing faces and recognizing
objects and making automatic uh folders
and categories for you like I went in
and I searched for just I just put in
coffee it showed me every picture of a
coffee cup I had ever taken I just
selected those hit make a new folder
from this and now those are all
organized so now I have my shoe box but
the the photos are in better Stacks now
so that's one of the great AI things
this this object recognition and that's
really good enough photos in the cloud
because yes I like organizing photos but
you know when you're at the bar and
somebody's like oh send me that picture
from like 2000 you're like it's
downloading it's downloading so you keep
everything natively on your device or do
you put everything in the cloud I find
things on my device as long as I had
that phone when I moved to a new one
then the old photos I keep up in the
cloud and I can't even if I need to but
cloud storage is so plentiful and so
inexpensive these days uh it's a great
way to keep things backed up and you can
even do Apple and Google photos and
Amazon photos so you have multiple Cloud
versions of it in case something happens
to one of them all right doing a
commercial break I got to ask you about
subscriptions because I think a lot of
us got subscriptions that we should oh
yeah right Dan Ackerman thank you so
much we appreciate you we'll be right
back